i'm brett bear i'm maria bartoromo i'm
brian kilmeade and this
is the fox news rundown
wednesday april 7th 2021
i'm dave anthony george's republican
governor
is pushing back on all the pushback his
state is getting
over a new election law that prompted
major league baseball to move the
all-star game out of atlanta
people are tired of this i've been
warning people they're coming to your
neighborhood next they're going to
boycott your business next
they're going to take over your sporting
event next i'm lisa brady
vaccination acceleration continues in
the u.s
but so does a race against covet as
virus variants find
younger targets so we're about to see a
major divergence in the data
we're going to see deaths and
hospitalizations come down and plummet
but yet we're still going to see cases
linger and that's really
we're witnessing two different age
groups there and i'm jason chaffetz
i've got the final word on the fox news
rundown
[Music]
now batting denver after major league
baseball called
georgia out over a new election law by
moving the all-star game to colorado
which president biden strongly supports
calling the new law
un-american and sick as democratic
critics allege republicans took action
after losing the presidential election
and the georgia senate runoffs
they're not changing their policies uh
to win more votes they're changing the
rules to exclude
more voters white house press secretary
jen saki republicans say that's not true
and senate minority leader mitch
mcconnell says baseball fans on the
right are irritated
my advice to the corporate ceos of
america is to stay out of politics the
ceos of two prominent atlanta companies
were also critical of the law prompting
gop senator rand paul to tell fox
we'll see how why they do when half of
the country quits drinking coca-cola
when half the country quits using delta
the state's republican governor
says major league baseball buckled under
pressure from the left
they've caved to the cancel culture and
the woke mob on this
there's no question about that georgia
governor brian kemp says he won't be
intimidated defending
the law i think the hypocrisy is just
running rampant i can't even keep up
with how much hypocrisy there is whether
it's new york voting laws compared tires
where major league baseball
is headquartered uh where delta's flying
into where coca-cola sells a lot of
product
or whether it's all-star game moving to
colorado that has
less early voting days than we do so it
continues on
it's not based on fact it's based on a
political narrative
and political pressure quite honestly
from the canceled culture groups that
are raising a lot of money off of this
and putting a false narrative out there
the commissioner of baseball said that
they fundamentally support voting rights
for all americans and
oppose restrictions to the ballot box
in you've been hearing this over and
over again that your law
and and sometimes the words in the
stories are dramatically or whatever
dramatically or take that word out
restrict access especially to maybe
black voters or minority voters what's
your response been
yeah what specific thing is he talking
about
i mean it's obviously not the
opportunity that we now have in georgia
for everyone to have a an additional
mandatory saturday
when they can vote in georgia
potentially have the option to be able
to vote if their county elects to
on two sundays i mean this is providing
more opportunities for people
to vote on the weekends in our state
it's simply
securing ballot drop boxes you know
they're they're saying that it's
restricting them and taking them away
they were never even in the law they
were done by uh
emergency rule because of the pandemic
under the public health state of
emergency we've now codified that
if we hadn't passed this law drop boxes
would have gone away completely
because they were never in the law we're
also requiring county elections
officials to continuously count the
votes
not starting and stopping so we have
timely results and people aren't in
doubt about what's going on
in the dead of the night and then we're
replacing the antiquated signature
matching process on absentee ballots
because we had a 351 percent increase
in the amount of mail-in ballots we got
in tying it to the voter id
requirement that we have for in-person
voting in georgia that we've had from
2006
and we'll give you a free one if you
don't have one so i'm not sure
what the commissioner is pointing to i'd
be interested to know that
now when it comes to voter id democrats
have opposed voter id for more than just
the last few days i mean this has been
an issue for them for a while and
they've over and over
said that voter identification for pover
at the polls or
in mail-in ballots will
disproportionately affect black voters
or
poor voters what's your reply to that
look at the facts
look at the number since we've had photo
id requirements or voter id requirements
in georgia since the mid-2000s minority
participation including
african americans latinos and other
groups has all
increased when i got elected in 2018
the we had the largest percentage of
black population voting in that
governor's race in the country
that cycle yet i was still called a
voter suppressor and
you know a racist it's just it's it's a
lie and that's what i've told a lot of
people dave
you know i've been very outspoken on
this because i know the truth is on my
side
and i'm looking in that camera and i'm
getting on the radio and i'm telling
people
somebody's lying to you you know
somebody's lying to you on this issue
whether it's president biden
stacey abrams the commissioner for major
league baseball
the ceos of coca-cola and delta
the ceos of of merck and
and former ceo of amex that are all
pushing this
nationally even though they live in
states that are more restrictive than us
but somebody's lying to you and it's not
me and you can fact check it all day
long the washington post did
and gave joe biden four pinocchios well
they gave him pinocchios when it came to
shutting down early voting at a certain
time
what is it for the hours of early voting
because
again a criticism of the of of the law
is that you have restricted
early voting and that you've also
criminalized handing out
water and food at a polling location
during a time where there are long lines
and people made a big deal about that as
well
well dave the fact of the matter is 134
of 159 counties in georgia are now going
to be
uh allowing more hours of voting
time under this legislation because we
have
put uniform requirements when in the
last election certain counties would not
be open
as much as other counties so to say
that's being a restriction is absolutely
ridiculous
we have 17 days of in-person early
voting
uh we have weeks of opportunities for
people to request
and vote an absentee ballot by mail and
then we have
you know 7 a.m to 7 p.m election day
voting so that that
argument just does not add up and what
they're saying is absolutely not true
the legislature did push the issue which
just about i think every state in the
country has restrictions
on voters when they're in line they vary
from you know
10 feet from a polling location to 300
something feet ours is 150 in georgia
you can absolutely bring food and drink
if you're a voter you can order a pizza
you can order grubhub you know ubereats
whatever you want to do but we're not
going to allow
you know third-party groups whether it's
the sierra club or the nra or whoever
else to come election near you
and give you out favors to sway your
vote while you're standing in line that
is
unlawful that is true in georgia also
county elections officials
can set up drink stations for voters
that may be in line
one of the things that is brought up by
critics is that you shrank
the window for requesting a mail-in
ballot
and also a lot of people want ballots to
be going out to anybody
just mail them all out to all registered
voters and in your law
you have to request one 78 days
or less out from an election
in georgia we don't think you should
just mail a ballot out to everybody
that's terrible ballot security in my
opinion if other states want to do that
that's certainly their right although
joe biden and the democrats want to undo
that with hr1 and sr-1
and federalized elections which is
another reason they are pushing so hard
on this issue they're trying to build
support
for a national takeover of elections
which would be a terrible idea when our
founders set this
process we have now up to avoid foreign
interference by allowing
states to do different things and to do
it the best way they see fit
led by their local and in state
governments which is the way it should
be
and then the window was shortened uh
which i think was definitely needed a
lot of other people did you still have
you know several months to request an
absentee ballot
before an election but if you if you
continue to have those long windows you
have
elections that run into one another one
other big issue for your critics
is that the law allows the general
assembly
to select the chair of the state
elections board rather than the
secretary of state
and that that board can investigate
county election boards and and the idea
behind this is
as i think stacey abrams said that it's
increasing
unfounded challenges of voter
eligibility that will no doubt lead to
racial profiling disenfranchisement and
seize power from election officials
well the general assembly obviously
pushed that narrative
because they felt like that you needed a
non-partisan person as head of the state
election board taken out of partisan
secretary of state i will let your
listeners know because they're not being
told the truth from stacey abrams and a
lot of other people
the state election board is already a
bipartisan board
democrats and republicans the the
parties make appointments to that board
and then the general assembly
appoints the other members and this last
one will be a non-partisan person
the the only reason and elect county
elections office would be
interrupted from doing their duties is
just because they're not running an
election
the way they're supposed to do governor
kemp got some support from another
republican governor on monday
when greg abbott refused to throw out
the first pitch at the texas rangers
home opener on monday
i could not associate myself uh with
major league baseball that had gone out
and done something that was
absolutely ridiculous and governor kemp
appreciated abbott's refusal
listen i appreciate governor abbott
being as mad about this issue as i am
and it's not just him i mean senator
tim scott i've been conversing with him
today and
he's very supportive he's sick of this
woke
you know canceled culture crowd that's
out there you got
senator tom cotton senator rubio making
great points about
china and cuba and major league
baseball's connection
to both of those countries that by the
way don't have elections
they don't have early voting and they
suppress democracy
but you know people are tired of this
i've been warning people they're coming
to your neighborhood next they're going
to boycott your business next
they're going to take over your sporting
event next and when you see major league
baseball
go in the way of making the sport
political it is a
it is going to it's going to be
devastating you know it's devastating
for me as a fan
it's devastating for millions of kids
across our country
and it's very harmful for a lot of small
business owners
in the great state of georgia and
specifically in the metro atlanta area
where the population by the way is 51
percent black
and when you're moving the game to a
state like colorado where they're
you know 10 african americans there very
condescending for the league to do that
former president trump has called for a
boycott of all the companies like major
league baseball
that that don't want as he said voter id
and free and fair elections
would you like to see the reverse do you
want the
boycott like that too well look these
companies are going to pay the price for
their political decisions because when
you get in
when you get in the middle of debates
like this when you don't know what
you're doing you're alienating a lot of
your customers in my opinion so we'll
see how
that plays out people have been very
vocal about that
you know i hate it for the atlanta
braves they did not support this
decision they did not agree that this
was a good move for the league
uh to take um and unfortunately they're
going to be
guilty by association and i've tried to
converse to a lot of fans that look
this is not the braves position and
they're like i don't care
it's a tragic thing it's unreal it
happened and we just got to stand up and
continue to push back and not take this
anymore
republican governor brian kemp from
georgia we thank you very much for
joining us today
thanks for having me on have a great day
[Music]
this is jason chaffetz with your fox
news commentary coming up
the united states is now on pace to hit
200 million covid shots
by president biden's 100th day in office
we vaccinated more people than any other
nation on earth
the vaccines have proven to be safe and
effective but he says now is not the
time to celebrate
or get complacent because we're not at
the finish line
in a life and death race new variants
of the virus are spreading and there's
moving quickly
cases are going back up his latest
appeal to the nation on tuesday to keep
following safety rules
echoes the concern of many health
officials especially over the uk
variant dr michael osterholm from the
university of minnesota telling fox news
sunday
he believes the u.s is already in a
fourth wave the only good news about
this
is that the current vaccines are
effective against this particular
variant b117
but in a sense this is a virus that is
now
50 to 100 percent more transmissible or
infectious than the previous viruses and
he calls it a game changer
because it's spreading in younger people
including school kids
the cdc director is urging more testing
in youth sports and other
extracurricular activities
also noting that the cdc still
recommends limiting those activities
she also says rising cases among young
adults are driving the overall increase
in u.s cases
which average more than 64 000 a day
in the latest seven day average we are
seeing increases right now in some of
the
northern midwest and new york tri-state
region
and massachusetts dr marty mccary is a
professor of surgery and health policy
at the johns hopkins university school
of medicine
a fox news medical contributor and
author of the price we pay
but by and large it's a seasonal
phenomena and it's really two pandemics
we're watching right now
one among older people people over 50 if
we can put that in a big group of older
and we're we're crushing that pandemic
we're doing great those are the people
that come to the hospital get sick and
die
and we're seeing deaths and
hospitalizations plummet in that group
and then the other pandemic are people
under 50. and we're seeing a lot of 20
and 30 year olds get infected we're
seeing in boston
a lot of people age 10 to 19 getting the
infection
and that infection that pandemic has
much much less severe consequences but
it's really
driving up the case numbers so we're
about to see a major divergence in the
data
we're going to see deaths and
hospitalizations come down and plummet
but yet we're still going to see cases
linger and that's really
we're witnessing two different age
groups there
remember some parts of the country right
now are doing doing great they're
crushing it
is this because the rising case numbers
is this because
the spread of the variance is outpacing
vaccinations well
i would not get too concerned about the
variants because they are a hundred
percent
encompassed by the vaccines in
preventing those serious outcomes of
death and hospitalizations
we are though seeing um the variants
circulate because
they're a little more contagious and so
if you're going to get the infection
right now
you're more likely to get it with a
variant circulating
but i've just sorry i've heard so much
fear-mongering with the variants i had
to give that disclaimer lisa
i understand i would be remiss though if
i didn't just ask you to weigh
in on the double mutant variant
what what is that yeah double mutant
sounds like some
alien that shows up in the middle of the
night with two heads you know like
it's not that so different it's not that
big of a deal okay
the variants are changes
in the protein lining of the virus
on the surface that's what mutations do
but by and large we have one main strain
of covalent 19 and that is covid19
there's many different mutations on the
surface of
hiv but ultimately we've had one hiv
virus
ever since it came on the scene same
with
sars cov2 or covet 19. we are still
dealing
with a virus that behaves and acts
fundamentally just as it did when we
first saw it
with a slight difference in how tightly
it binds to the ac2 receptor in the lung
it can bind a little more tightly it can
be a little more contagious but by and
large we're still dealing
with one virus one main strain and a
strain that is
entirely encompassed by the vaccines
now even though younger people are
where rising case numbers are being seen
right now
there's a recent poll that found a
growing number in generation z
don't plan to get vaccinated more than
one in four
compared to just five percent who plan
to skip vaccination
in an nbc poll last year how big a
problem is that for everybody else like
how many people need to skip it
before we jeopardize herd immunity i
don't think it's a big problem first of
all remember among
those who are refusing to get vaccinated
half of those are already immune from
natural immunity from prior infection
that works it's pretty powerful
you know we've heard this discussion in
the past with
vaccine hesitation and those numbers
decline over time people find getting
the vaccine to be more relatable when
they see other people
people they know and like get the
vaccine i'm not that concerned i will
tell you that with kids
just from being a doctor i will tell you
that with kids
you don't want to just scare them into
things risk appeals to some kids
and so what you want to do is ex really
explain to them the rationale
and i think if anything the reason i i
encourage young people who are healthy
to get the vaccine
is you don't want to deal with the
long-haul symptoms yes your risk of
mortality is exceedingly low but you
don't want to deal with
long-term disability from the long-haul
symptoms
well yeah and i think for younger age
groups in particular maybe feeling like
life is starting to feel more like a
return to normal
i mean overall is like is the sense of
urgency
slipping away at this point i think it
will this summer
because what's going to happen is we're
going to be crashing into herd immunity
here in late april and may
depending on the part of the country you
live in and the media will stop
covering this and what's going to happen
is it'll be like the opioid epidemic
where overnight we stop the coverage on
the opioid epidemic and people assume
it's gone and so
um i i'm concerned that people are gonna
perceive
very little risk and just forego the
vaccine when in fact it's important to
get it for the fall
to prepare for what probably will be you
know a coronavirus that circulates in
the fall that may look like what we
otherwise would call a mild flu season
but it's something we need to be
vigilant about do you think there's also
coveted confusion fatigue for some in
the public because there has been some
missed mixed messaging like the recent
cdc guidance that
you have a lower risk of traveling if
you're vaccinated but
you still shouldn't travel basically
well i would even go further lisa i
would not just call it
covet fatigue on the messaging i would
say bad guidance we've gotten a lot of
bad guidance
the public health officials have just
been making stuff up as they go
arguing common sense when they want you
to do something
using far-reaching hypotheses to come
out with
fears that are not supported by the data
i mean look at
all of the the the language which has
just not been
accurate right the twindemic remember
that last fall that was supposed to
happen never happened the twin democ of
flu and covid colliding together
every event every demonstration public
gathering whether it's a rally or a
demonstration
if it's a super bowl or a holiday we're
always
told that this is going to create a
surge on top of a surge well
we do see some small increases after
those events and people are letting down
their guard when they shouldn't but
let's put things in perspective and
we're seeing it right now where we're
doing
really well on the numbers i mean some
parts of the country are doing
so well it's looking really promising to
be back to a normal life
soon you know a return to in-person
learning for schools around the country
is one of those things that's kind of
one step forward two steps back for some
districts
some colleges have already said that
they will require
proof of vaccination which is you know
this issue of so-called vaccine
passports is kind of you know
being debated around the country right
now are those kind of debates
a distraction from focusing on
beating the virus i think that the
vaccine passports need to include
people with natural immunity from prior
infection remember about
107 million
americans have been vaccinated now but
another
107 million americans to 130 million
americans
have antibodies from prior infection
that's that's they have natural immunity
so are we only going to recognize those
with antibodies from vaccines
and not recognize those who have
antibodies from prior infection it's not
right
i know you've talked about hurt immunity
for
much of the country let's say perhaps by
the end of april
but um in europe there have been some
new lockdowns recently
can we avoid that in the us
because we do tend to follow their
trajectory
at least for much of this pandemic and
they've
they've had numbers really hitting
heading in the wrong direction
that's right they've had a real tragedy
with a resurgence in most of europe and
that's because their vaccination rate is
pathetic
they did a terrible job contracting for
the vaccines they also put all their
eggs in one basket with the oxford
vaccine
so we're talking about countries now
that are struggling with
surges because they've got a 10 11 12
immunization rate we in the u.s have 41
percent of adults now vaccinated we're
way ahead
and we're not going to see the surges
that we're seeing in europe right now
because we are following the path of the
uk and israel
and when you look at the data there by
the way the uk which is
part of europe has not had surges okay
and the reason that they're different
from say france and germany which
had the same level of restrictions is
the reason they're different is
the vaccination rates in france and
germany are low
11 12 percent and in the uk
it's 62 percent so what's the take-home
message
when you get a lot of people vaccinated
you don't have to worry about
resurgences
forth waves and other increases and i
think right now
we can look at the data from israel and
say hey when you get about 50
of adults immunized that's when numbers
really start dropping like a rock
the key numbers that is death and
hospitalizations
that's what we're about to see now you
could argue that's what we're seeing now
already since
um the cdc's director dr wolinski issued
the impending doom scare deaths are down
uh 15 that was only eight days ago she
said that deaths are down 18
15 to 18 since then so you would argue
overall we are on the right track we're
still on the right track
we're not going to have a true second
wave we're going to see a
regional increase in cases among young
people
and we're seeing that in michigan the
new york tri-state area and parts of
massachusetts
but otherwise we're headed towards a
trajectory of having
very strong population immunity which is
the combination of natural and
vaccinated immunity now
slowing it down breaking the cycle of
transmission
and when you go out now and you sit in a
public area remember
upwards of half to two-thirds of the
people there
have immunity dr marty mccary thank you
as
always for your time good to be with you
lisa
[Music]
fox nation presents podcasts women of
the bible speak
i'm shannon breem host of fox news at
night and author of the new book
women of the bible speak the wisdom of
16 women and their lessons for
today subscribe now on apple podcast
spotify
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you
download your podcast
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
jason chaffetz
what's on your mind when you hear that
democrats are about to spend
2.2 trillion dollars
more than half the total amount this
country collects in tax revenues in a
given year
you might imagine that money is for
roads highways bridges and ports
you would be less than 10 right
that's the amount of this behemoth
spending bill
that actually dedicates to those
priorities
the rest of the money is being used to
grow government and subsidized
well-heeled democratic constituencies
ditto for the last covet relief bill
of which roughly 10 percent funded covet
relief
already the biden administration is
talking about another
one trillion dollar infrastructure bill
this fall
the last time democrats held majorities
in congress we saw the same thing
the obama-era stimulus known as the
american recovery
and reinvestment act arra
intended to fund shovel-ready projects
yielded far less than 10 percent for the
projects
used to sell the bill this is disaster
liberalism leveraging a crisis to
transfer huge
sums of money out of the productive
economy and
into government coffers in my new book
never let a crisis go to waste the truth
about disaster liberalism
i unmask the deceptive tactics
used to subvert the democratic process
using the threat of an impending crisis
democrats justify
enacting expensive unpopular and
unconstitutional policies
disguised as crisis relief the latest
crisis
is infrastructure but the crisis relief
is the green new deal in disguise
infrastructure
is the spoon full of sugar to make
profligate spending go down
and once we swallow the spending we are
expected to ingest the economy killing
tax hikes that will follow
in the infrastructure bill money funds
job-killing green new deal initiatives
corporate welfare to favored industries
new government programs that favor
democrat-run urban centers and port
cities
and billions in government slush funds
with little accountability
that bill spends more on electric
vehicle subsidies than on infrastructure
that's great for tesla buyers but how
much help do they really need
but it's not just the spending that is
so damaging
when you actually read the bill text
you'll find the same provisions
again and again attached like barnacles
to every must-pass
piece of legislation giveaways to unions
bailouts to profligate spending blue
states
economy choking tax hikes and vast
transfers of income from private to
public sector
the standalone bills that don't stand a
chance of passing without bipartisan
support
get chopped up and embedded into the
popular relief bills
that's why the disasters come in so
handy
they provide a vehicle to move
legislation
that could not otherwise gain popular
support
these bills are marketed as manna from
heaven
but they send the bulk of the feast to
government
and special interest leaving middle
class americans to
settle for the crumbs and leaving their
children
to pick up the tab i'm jason chaffetz
host of the jason in the house podcast
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown
stay up to date by subscribing to this
podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com and for
up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic publisher of the federalists
and i'm inviting you to join a new
conversation with the smartest thinkers
out there about the country and where
we're going subscribe to the ben dominic
podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcast.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes